these sculptures which we see here are
more than a family's aesthetic
expression they provide subjects for
conversation and exemplars for personal
behavior and they're designed to do so
the notion is that the space is
decorated to reflect its use and we see
this in Cicero's letters the Roman
orator Cicero Road number of letters
that are contemporaneous with the villa
of the papyri and in me as he's writing
to a friend in Greece pleading for
thematically appropriate sculptures for
his Villa and Cicero's letters say
things like why are you sending me more
athletes I'm not building a gymnasium
sending me busts of philosophers I want
to reflect on the philosophers and so
he's creating a space that's considered
appropriate for only certain types of
decoration and here's the key thing here
Cicero is intending to engage with this
decor as he goes through the space
so his Paizo spends the afternoon in the
gardens he'll pass through a series of
spaces decorated with groups of marble
and bronze sculptures and I want to take
a look at a couple of reconstructions of
these now we have a couple here in the
studio and they're marvelous
reconstructions of the actual sculptures
that we have from the villa here on my
right is a bust of the Greek god
Dionysus and Dionysiac imagery is
considered particularly appropriate for
garden spaces Dionysus of course is the
god of wine the god of vineyards and
this is particularly important that we
see his work in outdoor spaces and so we
see this Dionysus bust here from the
villa of the papyri well there's other
types of spaces as well for example on
my left is a bust
smaller in scale obviously which is
always called Seneca and it's thought to
in fact be an image of the philosopher
Seneca and this I think is marvelous
because it reinforces what Cicero says
that he has particular needs in his
villa and he wants to see busts of
philosophers and here in the villa of
the papyri we see this as well images of
philosophers so we've got two great
component
of greek classical culture Dionysiac or
greek mythological culture as well as
the culture of greek philosophy we see
these here in these in these busts and
they were part of the of the overall
display in this enormous garden space we
also have some images for you of some of
the other sculptures from inside this
garden and here's one from inside now on
display in the National Archaeological
Museum in Naples it's a life-size bronze
sculpture which replicates apparently a
famous sculpture from the Greek
Classical period it's also Dionysiac and
it's bronze what we have here in the
villa of the papyri is the largest set
of bronze sculptures from any site in
the ancient world anywhere Greek or
Roman many of them are Dionysiac and
they seem designed to reflect this
outdoor space and this notion of the
power of Dionysus and in his role in the
natural world others however are
mythological a Greek myth is the most
important and common subject for Roman
domestic space it's considered to be
didactic and moralizing and what we have
for you on the screen for you to take a
look at is a set of bronzes also from
the garden at the villa papyri these are
the de naiads
these are the daughters of the Greek
King Daenerys and in Greek mythology
these daughters committed an act of
gross in piety on their wedding night
they killed their husbands it was a well
a power struggle between two brothers
about who's going to be king and a
question of succession and so de næss
encouraged his daughters to kill their
husbands the sons of his brother so that
they couldn't succeed to the throne and
they did so and they're punished in the
underworld forever by having to perform
a task that can never be completed in
this case they're carrying water and if
you look at these images so you see the
one in the center is holding her hand
above her head
she'd be originally holding a
water-jug these donated sculptures are
considered to be didactic that is their
moralizing they tell you a story and
they tell you a lesson but I want to
point out that none of these sculptures
from this entire display none of the
bronzes none of the marbles have any
names on them they're all effectively
for our purposes completely anonymous
the expectation is that the viewer not
only will recognize the imagery from an
appreciation of the iconography here but
it will know the narrative because it
doesn't do me any good to say oh these
are women you have to know that they are
the de naiads and you have to know that
they are the de neige it's in the
underworld being punished for their
active impiety because that completes
the story and so the narrative here is
left up to the viewer so this is art
that is very demanding of the viewer
well in addition to the mythological
sculptures that we have the de naiads
and the Dionysus imagery there is a set
of remarkable busts of Greek kings and
Generals in the garden and this I think
is remarkable because many of these
Greek kings are ones who fought against
Rome it's got a nice image here of the
Greek king and general Antiochus one of
the successors of Alexander the Great
the founders of the Hellenistic kingdoms
that succeeded the Empire of Alexander
there's Antiochus and another image I
want you to take a look at and this one
I think is even more remarkable because
this is the Greek King Perseus Perseus
was the king of Macedon and he fought a
very brutal war against Roman generals
and yet Paizo has a bust of Perseus here
in his garden I mentioned when we were
looking at the house of the faun that
was one of two spaces in the Vesuvian
lands that's primarily decorated with
imagery from Greek history it has in
that to blind him of the house of the
faun the great Alexander the great
mosaic showing Alexander a Greek
historical figure there as a model for
behavior well here is the second one the
villa of the papyri is that second space
which is decorated with an
number of images more images from Greek
history than Greek mythology well in
addition to those Greek kings and
Generals we also have a bust of Skippy
Oh africanus Skippy Oh africanus of
course was the first roman who built a
seaside villa and it reveals I think the
notion of this inclusive cultural world
that provides models for Roman elite
behavior from wherever from either the
Greeks or the Romans